abandoned
abused neglected dumped
these dogs are some of the lucky ones
that have been rescued from inhumane
conditions
and now live in a shelter but their
chances of finding a home
are about to dwindle starting on july
14th
the united states will ban dogs from
entering for at least a year from 113
countries considered high risk for
rabies
qatar is on that list 80 percent of the
dogs
here at qatar animal welfare society are
re-homed in
or transferred through the u.s with
little paperwork
and no quarantine required more than a
million dogs are sent to america every
year
qatar is such a small country with such
a transient population
that the actual group of people that can
adopt a pet is so small
compared to the number of animals that
can that are looking for a new home
that cutting out half of our adoptions
overseas will absolutely [ __ ] us
if we can't re-home our animals we can't
take in more animals off the streets
the u.s centers for disease control and
prevention says some dogs receive
fraudulent vaccines abroad
and the u.s does not have the number of
facilities needed
to house those that are denied entry at
u s airports
in a statement to al jazeera the cdc
said many vaccination programs in
countries around the world were
suspended or canceled
during the covet 19 pandemic as a result
the risk of importing a dog with rabies
may be higher
rabies and dogs has been eliminated from
the united states since 2007
but remains prevalent overseas 59 000
people die
every year from the disease every dog at
this shelter is vaccinated
even though cases here are rare 19 years
of living in qatar and rescuing dogs
and dealing with stray animals on a
daily basis we've never come across
we've never heard of
we've never been notified of any kind of
case of rabies in qatar at
all some pet adoption agencies have had
to tell some hopeful owners
that their dogs won't be able to make it
out in time we're talking about u.s
military troops here who i'm sure the
cdc would not directly
mean to implicate in this these soldiers
are no longer going to be able to take
home
that animal that they befriended and who
has become their emotional support
there are some exceptions to this ban
guide dogs will still be allowed to
enter the united states
and some personal pets will be accepted
on an extremely limited basis
but the reality of this ban for dogs
like this
mean that they'll be spending longer in
the shelter and might have a harder time
finding a forever home
dogs that have been here longer and
breeds that struggle in the summer heat
like huskies and german shepherds are
top of the list to go
for the rest they'll have to continue
waiting in the desert for a second
chance
leah harding al jazeera doha